let's talk about how to get rid of your
skin tags and warts within one day
hopefully now many times it'll actually
disappear within one day 24 hours
but sometimes it actually shrinks and it
takes a little bit longer with some
people it could take up to four to six
weeks so give it a little time but this
remedy is extremely effective so skin
tags and warts what is the actual cause
well most of the information i could
find points to the hpv virus human
papilloma virus this is an extremely
common virus that infects
325 million women worldwide and there
are over 100 different types and 14 of
them have the ability to cause cancer
but realize that what determines someone
getting cancer or not is really the
epigenetic factors those are the things
that are superior to your genes like the
environment
what you expose yourself to your
lifestyle what you eat
your stress level and so you can do a
lot of things to keep this virus in
remission now when you get infected with
a virus
your immune system is going to fight
that virus but these viruses are very
very stealth and so they go into hiding
and they don't necessarily bother
anything so there's no red flags for
your immune system to find them and so
they just wait and they wait and they
wait until your immune system
becomes lowered let's say you get older
you go through stress
and then it comes out and it kicks you
when you're down in fact the cause of
cervical cancer for women is hpv and
this is the fourth most common cause of
cancer in women so it's a pretty big
deal but there are several studies i'm
going to list down below that show
that you can use a simple home remedy
called iodine to help make these skin
tags and wards go bye-bye so one study
showed 77 percent success rate but i'm
not satisfied with 77 we want to bring
it closer up to 100 percent so this is
why we're going to add
garlic now garlic is not only deadly to
viruses but also to cancer the
phytonutrient allicin in garlic
suppresses
viruses from invading different areas of
the body including the cervix and anal
canal now there's some great day that i
found in a patent someone was attempting
to get the patent using
topical iodine to help suppress the hpv
virus to inactivate this virus to
decrease the risk of cervical dysplasia
and to prevent cancer in the uterus and
the anal canal so i'll put that
information below now in this natural
home remedy you're going to be using two
things you're going to be using povidone
iodine which you can get pretty much
anywhere in the drugstore and you're
going to be using some fresh garlic now
there's a few things that you need to
know about pobidone iodine
number one it's less toxic than other
types of iodine it's very soluble so it
can actually absorb into the skin and do
its magic this type of iodine is also
used to treat burns and vaginal
infections
and apparently microbes don't become
resistant to it like an antibiotic and
other forms of treatment so iodine is
really good to suppress viruses bacteria
fungus mold parasites
and so is garlic garlic is antimicrobial
as well so the combination of both of
these items is going to be very deadly
to that skin tag and wort so this is how
you make this concoction you take a
little dish
and you crush up some garlic okay crush
it up to the point where there's some
juice in the garlic now you're going to
get another dish with a couple drops of
pobidine iodine and then you're going to
take a very small amount i'm talking
about maybe an eighth of a teaspoon of
the garlic juice and some of the
material just a tiny bit
and mix it with the iodine just mix it
all up in a solution then you'll take
that solution
and apply it topically right over the
skin tag for the wart
and then cover it up with a band-aid
then you're going to take this garlic
cover it up with a little saran wrap
keep it in the refrigerator it's going
to last one day because what you want to
do is you want to do two applications
per day so you can use the same garlic
that you crushed in the morning and
again just put a couple drops of iodine
with it mix it up apply it to the same
skin tag and wart and then cover it up
with another band-aid so you're just
repeating the same thing twice a day and
you're going to do this every day until
this skin tag or wart is completely
gone now what determines the speed at
which it goes away is probably related
to
your
health you may be a diabetic or
pre-diabetic or have very severe insulin
resistance because diabetics or people
with blood sugar problems have a higher
risk of getting skin tags and warts and
so there's definitely a discorrelation
between insulin resistance and viruses
so as a side note if you
haven't already
gone on the ketogenic diet and practice
intermittent fasting
i would highly recommend you do that
because those two things are very
powerful and can help you in the long
run to prevent them from coming back now
some people will see a complete
disappearance within about seven hours
but like i said before it could take
some weeks even up to six weeks
but you should see a gradual reduction
in the size over time now the garlic
that you use when you crush it
should last several days however we want
to make sure that the potency
is at its highest level so i'm going to
recommend you use a fresh clove of
garlic every single day and also when
you crush the garlic it takes about 10
to 15 minutes
for the phytochemicals to become
activated but it doesn't really matter
because you're going to be putting this
material with iodine underneath the
band-aid so it'll have a time to absorb
into the skin and do its magic now i
also recommend that you eat garlic
during this process and you use it in
your food you can get garlic powder as a
supplement
and on top of that start taking zinc
zinc is also very beneficial for viruses
especially hpv
so i would recommend taking about 50
milligrams of zinc every single day
in a blend of trace minerals if you want
more information on that i put a link
down below but the fact that you have a
skin tag and a wart could indicate
that your blood sugars
are too high
your a1c might be a little bit higher
you may have insulin resistance
so this is why you should start the
ketogenic diet as well as in a minute of
fasting i put a real simple to
understand playlist of your exact steps
right here check it out